welcome to see you playing Rick's on
Gracie again yeah I had this opponent
earlier when here basically lost on time
from the from the get-go I spending
really lots of time so let's see what we
get here this line and the Kings
engineer i'm not a huge expert here or
any expert at all yeah this is preparing
i think some kind of banco maybe this
cannot be so bad do you five and then be
five really no seems to be aiming for
some kind of benoni so i'm going to
prevent b5 him so castles yeah taking it
is kind of stupid so let's do this I
didn't want to play see txt five and so
this sum is then a modern benoni kind of
position where he's probably happy that
term he has traded the light squared
Bishop this is why I avoided that so
going to play like this night a three
and kind of slow ish slowish play
like a hundy in significantly worse him
I still have a little bit of space this
is not not get completely equal but
close to it
yes putting quite a lot of stuff on the
file I can already draw with 92 93 but
it's not really the group go Liam now
can i play for more with 92 probably not
okay anyway I don't want to draw here
think I'm slightly better so I'm going
to play him no mind up his end games for
example a little bit more comfortable
for white f5 Wow okay
I didn't expect that move but it's not
so bad yeah but the f5 in all those
minor piece and games lose some of some
of that peer of course welcome I can
stop play this position without any
problem
check check so let's see can we do
something here or not hmm yeah i can go
a five and try something on the
queenside i think i'm going a five it's
not a bad move anyway
it should end in a draw of course I'm
not saying a better and just see if I
can try try something mmm can I get
before played somehow or is that not
even even on yeah let's go there can I
do something night coming over don't
really see much King c3 is not a good
idea then he's got maybe I can try that
King e5 it's not doing this ok
before as an idea now right so he
probably goes kingi 50 so that he has
after before takes King you for no okay
check see getting around here or
something okay i'm doing this i think
it's it's an idea
if he moves his night I have 94 taking
g6
check well can you five so going back
here and again if he moves us night I
got 94 which again probably does not
need too much but i just wanted to
continue a little bit and see if I can
do something yeah but is this really
going to help them a lot if I go King
here what then like a five or something
I don't know f5 King be five that's
really good
that's so kind of kind of interesting
here yeah I think 85 is happening on a
5v5 King b5 a forum where I can take it
huh
what is he doing now check
he for King be 63 ok I can sacrifice
yeah of course I didn't really didn't
really think about that one yeah that
that's probably going to be a draw time
morning maybe guys he's getting is
getting at the pawn can i play for wind
somehow let's try a king III 95 95 d
five Kings in 3d for King situ I don't
think I can win here 95 t5 King see 3d
[ __ ] to teen now thats not working ok
let's play let's let's take the troll
game drawn ok wow yeah i was told some
points in this end game i'm surprised
that he actually aligned all this but
chatons maybe it still is ok check 5 and
this is really this is a draw yeah that
was really not very exciting I thought I
have something about f5 is this kutia
that gives black enough space in this
position enter just you check some
around equal yeah it's not much to look
at all seem to like a very correct draw
ok thanks for watching